[موسيقى]
الاسعار دي
عباره عن شنو يعني الناس مضغوطه من ناحيه
الترحيل او بمعنى تاني انه البضائع
الموجوده في السوق
ما يفقد راس ماله وما يفقد سرعته في نفس
الوقت
سبحانه
[موسيقى]
حاليا متواجدين في سوق
الحركه طبيعيه الحياه طبيعيه في اقبال على
سوق في قوه شرعيه لكن ضعيفه في بعض
المحلات مقفله لكن الوضع الطبيعي اكثر من
باقي الاسواق مثلا نحن كنا
غيرنا راينا جينا على لانه في حوالي يعني
قالوا
في حركه بتاعه كده يعني زي ما نقولوا سرقه
الوضع ما امان حاليا للسوق الشعبي السوق
الشعبي باعتباره امان اكثر
امان اكثر من السوق الشعبي
لكن الامور مستقره الحمد لله والحركه
مستغره ما في حاجه الحمد لله والشكر لله
ونسال الله انه السلام على السودان وعلى
وطنا الحبيب
وان شاء الله
[موسيقى]